we have a voicemail number that number
is 219
to david p here's a caller who says
woke and cancellations are
merely constructs that don't exist
what let's take a listen
yes sir um i'm calling
simply because the terms
woke and cancel don't exist
they are constructs that have been
created by social media
it would be useful if you stopped
promoting them
well first of all i don't really promote
them
we do talk about them on the show
in a sense isn't everything a construct
i mean like i guess
a rock isn't a construct it's a physical
rock
but aren't most political discussions
made up of constructs and things that as
societies we've agreed
i don't know i'm having trouble
following it let's listen to a little
more these
are words that people think they know
what they're talking about
rest assured they do not um
woke well what does that mean um
that you suddenly become aware of the
fact that there is injustice in america
uh cancel well you know we have other
terms and phrases for
disavowing those who fail to meet our
criteria
but you know imagining that this is in
some way
associated with a culture is just
bizarre
so i'm hoping we can get you to stop
using these words as they have been
presented so i often get voicemails
asking me not to do something that i've
not done
or responding to things i haven't
covered i don't use the term woke in an
unironic way
the only times i've used the term woke
are point fun
at its absurd usage by others
so i mean listen in a sense all of these
concepts are constructs we we always
have
synonyms we can use but i don't really
know
what exactly the point is of the call
particularly since
when i talk about the left can't i'm
sorry when i talk about
the right has canceled someone while
claiming to be against cancellations
i am sort of using the term
tongue-in-cheek
when i talk about woki-ism
it's often a reaction to the right's
kind of weird use of it
i don't use the term woke in a real way
so maybe the caller and i are on the
same page but at the same time maybe
we're not i don't really know
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today joe biden has
cancelled speaking of which donald
trump's planned national garden of
american heroes and it's triggering
people and
we're going to talk about the origins of
it and much more this is a funny story a
bunch of people sent me harry styles
who's a british musician
got an award recently and he seemed to
no longer have a british accent and
i have a bunch of funny related stories
about this
uh and i think it'll be an entertaining
story at minimum
and then we do still have at least in
theory the rescheduled
olympics uh coming um later this year to
japan
80 of the japanese oppose the olympics
being done in japan this summer
we're going to talk about why what's
going on the preparations that are being
made could it be done
safely etc etc um and much more
including some of the upcoming plans for
the show over the next
few weeks don't miss today's bonus show
that's just a suggestion it's not an
authoritarian demand it's just
i think you would enjoy the bonus show
you can get into instant access to it by
signing up at joinpakman.com that also
comes with many other great benefits
including the commercial free
version of the daily audio and video
show
the members only newsletter invitations
to occasional
members only town halls and other events
and the pleasure of
knowing you're supporting alternatives
to homogenous
corporate media sign up at
joinpakman.com and i will see you in
mere moments
on today's bonus show